that's close to your hand i was worried
about that on the day well it's just
scary because you really have to sell
that you're hitting really hard you'd be
surprised to find out just how difficult
it was to film some of our favorite
season four moments of stranger things
is going to be
beautiful
from being mounted to a wall for hours
painful fight sequences to hoppers near
frostbite you definitely need a high
pain tolerance to visit hawkins
it was crazy i mean i hope you guys
liked it number one this time we're not
talking about eddie's sick guitar this
isn't the day that the axe yep this is
that day when filming the big showdown
at the creel house joe kiri had a major
moment where vekna's vines grab his axe
and pull him against the wall but if
you've seen all of our other videos
where we break down stranger things as
cgi you'd know vacna's vines aren't
actually there what we're really seeing
is joe kiri pretending like his arm is
being pulled back by swinging the axe
backwards this is where the danger
happens one reacts really hard and it
just slid out of your hand yeah in the
butt and went directly into camera we
don't know about you but we'd love to
see how that shot turned out you know a
lot of adrenaline going they'd never
done anything like this it was like the
fight day number two also known as the
demogorgon fight now it's not like we
would expect a russian prison fight to
be the safest thing to shoot but as far
as dangerous scenes go this is
definitely up there the duffer brothers
actually sacrificed a bit of creative
vision to keep their crew safe they
originally envisioned the sequence done
in one shot but because of how dangerous
the stunts were they decided against it
they ended up doing a few shots and just
stitching them all together it really
was a coordination of a lot of different
departments just to get here number
three more like running through that
slime sadie sink and her stunt double
went through a week-long ringer getting
this scene shot she was standing in a
real rocky bloody kind of pan not only
that but sadie had to bob and weave like
there were actual objects falling from
the sky i'm just remembering how
slippery the ground was and how careful
i had to walk on it sadie's stunt double
also had to take a few gnarly falls into
the bloody water at the end of it
like it feels real like the stakes are
really high it was not like the easiest
set to film on number four similar to
like a tv oh yeah natalia is actually
one of the most brutal because she's at
an angle
we mentioned earlier that vekna's vines
weren't there when filming so in those
moments where steve robin and nancy are
pinned against the wall in the creel
house they were really just mounted
there with clips into a harness it was
really hard to get you guys up there so
they would just leave you up there yeah
hours number five we're talking lots and
lots of salt millie bobby brown goes
full method in this stranger thing
sequence for starters she was inside
that tank for a few days for at least 10
to 12 hours a day and couldn't hear a
thing because her ears were underwater
the entire time in an interview with
variety millie talks about her struggle
with claustrophobia during filming i
suffer from claustrophobia so when we
closed the tank i definitely felt like
oh my gosh i am 11. i am really going
through this i feel like it was just a
crazy episode number six we're talking
emotional and physical i was supposed to
do something but i was just like making
a sound like
by the end of shooting the finale
particularly the attic scene caleb
mclaughlin had been through a lot he has
a major fight scene with mason dye's
character jason which took an incredibly
long time to get down i don't know why
but i remember knowing that i had to do
it i prepared for it mentally it was a
long day by the end of it when he's
screaming for max his emotional
intensity is through the roof he even
ad-libbed a few lines because of it he
was doing so much physical activity and
screaming so much he nearly lost his
voice it was crazy but it was like
really fun to film though number seven
no amount of thermal socks could help
david harbor with this we're sure you
all noticed his character the legendary
hopper making his grand escape from the
ussr totally barefoot yeah that was all
real it's really not pleasant
for your
bare feet to be on snow for a long
period of time
needless to say he much preferred his
time filming in atlanta over the
freezing chaos that was hopper's journey
through lithuania number eight we're
definitely sensing a theme here sadie
and her stunt double spent a fair amount
of time strapped into harnesses and
being pulled around there was like a
rope tied to my ankle and then dragged
me across the floor not only that but
the stunt double was actually pulled by
three guys across the floor as they
pulled her up and mounted her onto a
pillar while we dragged the stunt max on
her belly and up against the pillar
number nine there's definitely a big
watery element of danger here joe kiri
had to break out all of his swim
training to dive 16 feet down into this
huge 40-foot tank how big do you think
it was guys like 40 feet it was a big
circle 45 it's probably a few gallons i
think yeah in preparation for the roll
joe took tons of swim lessons so he
could pass as steve harrington captain
of the swim team and hot shot lifeguard
i got to kind of showcase this different
side of the character
number 10. not quite dangerous more like
straight up terrified we all know vecna
is incredibly scary and almost
completely done up with practical
effects so naturally he makes quite the
impression he snapped his neck and
looked at me and i'm there and i'm like
fully in it like staring at people
grunting growling millie had no idea
vecna was gonna look like that she
thought he was going to be all cgi she
was utterly terrified she couldn't even
go through with the scene the whole
rehearsal i was crying truly though who
wouldn't freak out seeing vacna pace
around your place of work especially
when it's jaime campbell bower
underneath all of it he didn't even
break character like talking to her
inside my mind as i know jamie's dead
like it's just and it's just regna
number eleven we had to include a few
season three bonuses
he's here
natalia dyer was super tough for this
season 3 sequence she definitely had to
endure a few migraines at the very least
days and days of those flickering lights
it's a quick way to get a migraine
even still with her pounding head she
quickly volunteered to do her own stunt
of being thrown into the wall i tried to
get them to let me do it but they said
no way she was probably better off
leaving it to the stunt professionals
she was great she did a really good job
repeatedly
thrown into the wall number 12 gotta
love a good hawkins scuffle in the
season three russian-based scene joe
kiri gets to do all of his own stunts
when fighting the guard whose actual
name is george this is george from
russia him and his family joined the
circus george had to take a ton of heavy
hits in this scene george had to get all
the heavy hits sorry jordan luckily
though he did have a stunt guy stand in
for one of the more dangerous scenes
where joe smacks him across the face
with a phone the phone itself was foam
but the next hit was one hundred percent
real then the stunt man he's actually
hitting his head on the desk and he hits
it hard i mean you can see this that's
not a joke this talented cast and crew
is definitely no stranger to danger
definitely exceeded my expectations with
how scary they could go
from onset mishaps to actual painful
exhausting sequences it seems like a
regular day at the office for them we
got through all the hard stuff now all
we need to do is the soldier just needs
to run in and and and fake death and
that's it which scene do you think was
the most difficult to film
you